[Musique]
ce mardi 6 avril le département et le
grand port maritime de la réunion ont
signé une convention cadre relative au
développement de la jeune arrière
portuaire propriétaire historique de 88
ha de foncier situé à proximité des
installations portuaires le département
a décidé d'accompagner le développement
du grand port maritime en mettant à sa
disposition 15 hectares l'enjeu de cet
arbre c'est non seulement de servir les
trafics portuaires
la raison d'être du port dont l'un doit
il payer
mais c'est aussi de donner à la réunion
des atouts supplémentaires pour du
développement économique en lien
notamment avec l'économie
on a toujours le souci au niveau du
confort de travail et en termes de
développement durable et le
développement durable c'est d'arriver à
concilier en même temps l'économie
l'environnement et le social
l'objectif pour la collectivité de
valoriser les terrains non utilisés en
vue du développement de l'activité
maritime mais aussi de l'activité
économique et industriel de cette zone
le transport des biens par lèvera
maritimes sont essentielles et ses
transports passe par la réunion il y à
une concurrence faut le dire même
terrorisait les api environnants mais
nous nous voulons faire de la réunion
fait en sorte que la réunion reste à
faire front à forte valeur ajoutée
c'est déjà le cas et nous devons rester
en pointe
parce que aujourd'hui le trafic
représente à peu près 6 millions de
tonnes et on envisage de passer à 8
millions de tonnes et bien cette
évolution rapide de trains du trafic
maritime engage la réunion et nous
engage tous ces bois cela que nous avons
signé cette convention
conscient de son rôle et de l'impact de
ses activités sur son environnement et
la biodiversité le grand port maritime a
souhaité apporter son soutien plan
quinquennal un million d'arbres pour la
réunion lancé par le département des
actions communes en faveur de la
biodiversité réunionnais seront menées
notamment sur des opérations de
plantation
[Musique]